at 7:30. Also, ASA is at 4:45. These
prayers have changed.
[Silence]
Never
mind.
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the book of prayer in the timings of
salah
and we had arrived at the narration of
Absah.
And abs
tells us that when he arrived in Medina,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
informed him of the times in which he
should pray and the times in which he is
not permitted to pray. And so he says
to this companion, our nar narrators,
our prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said
[Silence]
he says pray
the prayer of mourning
is referred to as al is referred to as
both are correct. And so he says pray
the morning prayer and then
refrain from praying until the sun rises
until the sun rises
clearly above the horizon. We mention
this is about 15 minutes. He says
because when the sun rises it rises
between two horns of a shaitan of a
devil and at that time the disbeliever
prays and makes sud towards it. He says,
[Silence]
He says, "And then after the sun has
risen clearly above the horizon, then
proceed to pray for indeed prayer at
that time," meaning between
you know after sunrise when the sun
rises
until high noon vhor time until high
noon when the sun is exactly in the
center of the sky the prayer is
witnessed by angels and witnessed
and documented and written. He says and
then refrain from praying once
a stick has no shade. So once there is
no more shade left around, this is the
time when we refrain from praying again.
What does that mean? When there is no
more shade, meaning when the sun rises
and it is exactly in the middle of the
sky. If we were on the equator where he
is sallaihi wasallam.
When the sun rises and it is right in
the middle of the sky, the the light is
coming straight down on things. There is
no shade to the right or to the left. At
this time, stop praying. refrain from
praying because at this time the
hellfire is kept up and reignited.
Right? He says,
"And continue in refraining from prayer
until the sun crosses its zenith and a
bit of shade starts to appear to items
again, then you may continue and proceed
to pray again." He says,
[Silence]
Muslim. He says, "After which continue
to pray and pray until you make
upon completing
once again refrain from praying."
And refrain from praying until the sun
sets. For indeed when the sun sets, it
sets just as it rises between two horns
of a shaitan. And at that time the
disbelievers are the ones who are
praying to the sun. This narration is in
Muslim. So what exactly does this
narration mean?
So in Jahidya people worshiped all kinds
of things and
they worshiped celestial objects and of
the most prominent of those is the sun
and the moon and Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala clearly prohibits in the Quran
and says
he says do not make sujud to the sun nor
to the moon rather make sujud to Allah
Now if a person were to wish to
prostrate himself and bow himself in
worship of the sun, when is the sun most
in front of him?
Obviously when it is first rising and
when it is setting, right? That's when
you can face the sun and it is appearing
to be straight in front of you and your
prayer and prostration is to the sun.
And so this is the most prominent time
when they would pray to the sun. And
they figured this into their lore and
into their belief system that the sun
makes itself available
for its worshippers to worship it while
it is setting and while it is rising.
And we are to thank the sun when it
rises and thank the sun when it sets.
And so the Muslim,
they are to
differentiate themselves from this.
And so it is not permissible to pray
during those optimal times when they
used to pray to the sun and to all
other things except for Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. And as for and this is the
meaning of
this is the meaning of between two horns
of a devil. He doesn't say
the devil. He says shan
a devil and that is that a shaitan in
the Arabic language is anything that
takes a person off of the path of Allah
or anything that distracts from Allah.
It is referred to as a shan by the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
So in
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam saw a
man
following a pigeon trying to catch it.
See I got your attention now.
And when he saw this
he said to the companions
listen to what he says. He commented on
this man and he said, "This is one devil
chasing after another." What does this
mean? Does this mean it's haram to
admire pigeons? No, of course not. But
have you ever met probably some of us
that have grown up overseas, you've met
some people, every village has one,
someone who is obsessed with pigeons.
They keep them on the roof. They upkeep
them. They right? You remember this? We
every every village has one of these
guys. But they become so obsessed with
this hobby that it distracts them from
everything. Everything. They don't take
care of themselves. They don't mind if
their house smells. They don't mind
anything. What matters is the pigeon.
And if and they might have 600 pigeons,
but if one of them is missing or walking
different, they will notice it
immediately.
And so this man is one of those guys,
one of the guys that is so absorbed in
this sport of pigeon racing and training
and collecting and so forth that it
distracts him from salah. It distracts
him from the worship of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. And even as the prophet
Muhammad himself sai wasallam is
present, he's not worried about that.
He's worried about the pigeon. Right? So
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam commented on this and said
he says one devil chasing another
doesn't mean all pigeons are devils
doesn't mean this man is a devil meaning
he's going to hell it means in this
respect
he is sidetracked and this is his fitna
this pigeon and so to him it is a
shaitan and to himself self.
He is a shaitan to others. All right? So
a shaitan in the Arabic language is used
to refer to anyone or anything that
takes or distracts from the path and the
remembrance of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And this is the meaning here
where he says when it sets when it ra
rises it rises and sets between two
horns of a shaan. Meaning this is the
time in which people in were taken from
the path of Allah because of the
movements of this sun.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]